salut à tous alors on se retrouve pour
une dernière vidéo avec saint-amand qui
il a va jouer un adversaire redoutable
il affronte polymorphie donc paul murphy
qui a acquitté le meilleur genre à
l'époque il a peu joué très longtemps
aux échecs
mais quand il est joué voiliers venus
suis devenu battre tout le monde
procédure j'arrête je veux faire du
droit et donc c'est une partie qui s'est
jouée à paris en 1858 et c'est parti
alors saint-amand avec les membres 4,5
kf3 kelly ces six petites italiennes ou
c5 c3 tv m6 et d4 donc maintenant on
voit plus aucune des parties avec
détroit pour pour défendre le pion mais
des caps mauvaise des quatre devraient
prendre le centre donc les noirs
prennent si on prend et font tomber
quatre échecs ça c'est hyper important
de pas à tergiverser
quel fou parce qu'on laisserait le
centre blanc et une attaque comme de 5
les foulées quatre échecs fait le job
puisqu'on fait échec food les deux il ya
un échange et on reprend le centre avec
des 5
je prends cavalli prend et ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on abat les blancs aux
options isolé mais petite avance de
développement et puis un jour
relativement actif quoi voilà ils vont
aussi d'occuper les colonnes et c'était
1 il a joué petit rock après ici un coût
qui est plutôt jouer maintenant c'est
d'homme b3 car ça peut conduire à des
nuls c'est une enfant caballé à 5 ces
dames à quatre échecs le cavalier
revient le truc c'est que les noirs ont
assez lentement québécismes on n'est pas
trop ravi de voir ça et ça on va mettre
la dame et sap et deux nuls après si les
noirs veulent jouer sur le coup et en
table et ça a été une partie par exemple
entre car yakine vaincre gawane jones et
caloin carrés qui nous dernier tournant
labiche kenzy le tata steel en 2018
voilà ce genre de trucs et voilà donc
les bleus en fait ils amènent leurs
cavaliers éventuellement et de l'autre
il peut arriver ici
tour au milieu face et ça va tellement
actif voilà c'est la compensation pour
le pion pour le pus m'isoler il veut nul
dans cette partie bon on n'est pas là
pour la regarder mais c'était juste un
petit dégression dans l'ouverture
toujours est il que c'est notamment à
jouer petit hank petit rock aussi il a
joué h3 là il n'y a pas envie de voir
rouge et quatre arrivées
même si au final c'est pas si grave le
tour c'est un serait intéressant et
surtout g4 on peut pas refaire h3 fou
ici et peut-être échange et ça me prend
hélas il y avait une partie jouée en
2015 avec perrine stein avec les blancs
contre kamski la jeune dame à quatre
noms pétition peut se demander qui se
passe sur ton c'est ça que ça a l'air
sympa de d'attaquer les deux mais juste
qui aurait pu prendre pour
intermédiaires preuve trois très bien et
le truc c'est après les noirs on allait
prendre ce pion
du coup ça explique pourquoi damas
quatre ça des champions on menace non
seulement pour ses 5 mètres sur
maintenant et qui aiment ce qu'ils
avaient échangé me l'a demandé 6
voilà c'était la partie et finie par une
nulle assez rapide en fait à ce moment
là ok mon possible mais donc voilà comme
je disais la partie l'afeas trois
cavaliers f4 et un coup difficilement
explicable en fait
zakaïev 4 le truc c'est que les noirs
attaques des quatre îles temps imparti
la sphère orange ii fait quand même
défendre ce pion le kubang carioca
travers logique on libère la dame pour
défendre l'option dans l'option des
câpres et peut-être ici le coup
intéressant pour les noirs c'est fou et
6 donc on va un buste abîmé la structure
aussi mais au moins on va éviter les
coups comme des saints qui a
définitivement on s'ouvre la colonne f
pour la tour et voit la banque tour la
donne des cinq tours à des 8
pas mal pour le nord mais bon jouable je
pense à peu près équilibrés comme
position soit il dans la partie
saint-amand afférents h2k il prend des
quatre bombes à sa permission quoi même
ces deux il a reculé saddam en d6
4 éventuellement avec une découverte on
croit h1 d'un matisse est mort fidèle à
son style un droit au but
un peu comme l'om quand il est là il te
menace directe fromage 3 france 3
pourquoi circuit on prend d'un projet un
objet de maths donc y défend un peu avec
dams et 3 août développement faut être 5
très bien trois veuves on y revient peut
colmater ce qui peut tour des huit tours
à des uns et la mort fut en actions bon
ouvrage 3 puis on prend h3 tour d'être
en voilà le problème des blancs
évidemment c'est concret une
interception s'il vous prend et pense
faire mater comme on l'a dit auparavant
avec dame et chaque rocher 1 est d'alger
de maths ça ça serait mac et mais du
goût inférieur il a essayé de rendre la
dame
oui j'ai tourné deux pièces ça va mais
sauf que ça va pas trop parce qu'il ya
le fou qui disparaît pas cette double
attaque et donc vers la pièce dont que
oui abandon partie petite fessée 1
mais bon c'était pas évident de les
confier cette époque là évidemment comme
je vous disais et puis saint-amand en
1858 était plutôt à la fin de sa
carrière
voilà alors comme le dirait notre ami
momo quoi c'est plus un talent c'est
sainte amende
il s'est fait manger tout cru des amis
et c'est la vérité mais bon voilà donc
morphine infiniment philippe bès donc je
ferai pas de vidéo spécialement sur
l'île parce qu'on se cantonne au genre
français mais si vous avez l'occasion de
regarder ces partis il y en a pas mal
par exemple à la partie de l'opéra qui
est peut-être la plus connue qui était
très jolie et donc pas je vous
recommande jeu offensif de belles
combinaisons mais c'était clairement
meilleur joueur mondial et cette
époque-là pas voilà et bah écoute et on
se retrouvera par la suite avec un
nouveau joueur
et puis moi je vous souhaite une bonne
journée une bonne soirée
voilà allez ciao ciao normal